when you see the players get the ball in
the hand for the first time it's a cross
between intrigue and excitement
it's great to see him try and bounce the
ball and to see it actually bounce away
it can make the best of people look
really really silly
the number one sport in australia is
australian rules football
it's basically a cross between rugby and
soccer
and the fans go crazy for it
there's one problem
they don't have enough tall people
so what do they do
they come to the states
this combines the usafl combine and uh
we started this four years ago
basically in a search for for guys six
foot seven and above
and these tall american athletes they
don't really need to know a lot about
australia
the home of the kangaroos i think i know
a lot of kangaroos i hear a lot about
kangaroos and spiders and snakes
in selecting these athletes we
predominantly look for guys that are
hungry
most of the participants predominantly
come from basketball
the concept of basketball in terms of
the athlete being in traffic and having
spatial awareness and those sorts of
things
is really transferable to our game
which is good news because less than two
percent of college basketball players
will make it to the pros
the australian football league gives
them another chance to live out their
dreams of being a pro athlete
most of the participants are quite
shocked when they see the game for the
first time
the question is what do the athletes
think of all this
when i got the kind of invite i thought
it was fake actually i thought it was a
scam
first thing i thought was a scam i
thought they was contacting the wrong
person actually what is australian
football
skepticism aside how do you teach these
guys a game they never even heard of
before
so the combine kicks off in the early
piece with the physical testing and then
start to build into the skills
the basics of handballing the ability to
see what they're like with their hands
then we can start to get into the more
competitive stuff where they might crash
and bash into each other which they love
that
this is mason cox
he played basketball at oklahoma state
two years ago he was just like one of
these guys on the combine
now he's playing professionally in
australia
they can be one of the 22 superstars out
there on an afl team
it's a fantastic opportunity for these
guys to continue their professional
career
you